all eyes also on our favorite Royals
especially with all of these rumors of
an ongoing rift between the Fab Four
well the family drama continues for the
Duchess today as her father Thomas
speaks out yet again she's always been a
very controlling person she's always
been in charge saying he won't be
silenced
Thomas Markel tells good morning Britain
he's been go stood by his Duchess
daughter and frozen out of her life hey
try to text her
I just haven't received any comment back
I'm here she knows it and I've reached
out to her and I need her to reach back
to me I love her very much
Marco believes Megan and Harry buy into
negative tabloid stories about him they
believe everything they read in the
papers and for the first year they were
telling me never believe those things
but now they were believing and thinking
I'm saying a lot of things though I'm
not saying the 74 year old retired
lighting director says he was not paid
for the interview and hopes the freeze
will end soon so he can meet his future
grandchild I'm certainly hoping that
everything goes well and that they
produced a beautiful baby and I'll get
this year little Megan or a little Harry
Megan's estranged sister Samantha is
also speaking out she criticized Megan
and Harry's holiday card which features
their backs turned saying is this
towards the world or just the raglan and
Markel family it's a bit sad Anna sort
lct that Megan Harry and their baby plan
to visit the u.s. and Canada in the fall
of 2019 the palace has yet to confirm
the trip which may not be formalized
until after the child is born
you